[Música]
ahora hablamos de economía aquí en
directo american france24 por ello me
acompaña en el estudio mi compañero
jorge hurtado jorge bienvenido vamos a
iniciar en eeuu porque se conoció el
dato de cifras de ofertas de empleo los
empresarios valentina y anunciaron menos
puestos de trabajo en mayo y esto se
podría interpretar como una señal de
debilitamiento de la economía aunque las
ofertas aún están por encima de lo
histórico en ese país existen 11,3
millones de ofertas de empleo a finales
de mayo según informó el departamento
del trabajo una cifra que es superior a
los casi 11,7 millones reportados en
abril pero pese a la reducción de
vacantes hay casi dos ofertas de empleo
por cada desempleado un enorme giro al
patrón histórico por ejemplo antes de la
pandemia siempre había más desempleados
que puestos de trabajo disponibles la
economía vive un momento complejo en
eeuu por un lado la inflación está
afectando los presupuestos familiares
obligando a los consumidores a gastar
mucho menos y el crecimiento se está
debilitando esto despierta temores de
una posible recesión económico para las
empresas continúan luchando por
contratar personal
es fuerte en los servicios relacionados
con los viajes y el entretenimiento los
economistas siguen de cerca las cifras
de las vacantes de trabajo en busca de
indicios de que el mercado laboral se
está enfriando lo que podría reducir la
inflación que está en su nivel más alto
en 40 años
así es jorge y nos quedamos en eeuu
porque se conoció en la minuta de la
última reunión de la reserva federal el
banco central estadounidense no descarta
nuevas subidas de los tipos de interés
mayores inclusive a las que ya han
aprobado en sus últimas reuniones para
contener esta inflación la última vez
que los banqueros se reunieron acordaron
una subida de los tipos de interés de 75
puntos básicos la más alta en 28 años
pero las actas muestran que los
gobernadores reconocieron que habrá que
estudiar aumentos más elevados si es
necesario pero nos preguntamos qué son
estas tasas de interés y por qué
hablamos tanto de ellas acá en economía
bueno las tasas de interés es el monto
que los bancos centrales de cada país
cobran a las entidades financieras por
prestarle dinero cuando los precios
suben la reserva federal de eeuu por
ejemplo que es la entidad financiera de
ese país busca desacelerar la economía
subiendo los tipos de interés o haciendo
más para obtener los préstamos es que
las personas compren menos usen menos
sus tarjetas de crédito y pidan mucho
menos préstamos para casas o carro
simplemente porque es más costoso que
obtengan estos créditos con intereses
altos al caer el consumo se desacelera
la economía y los precios teóricamente
deberían de bajar pero si los precios
bajan demasiado se puede provocar una
recesión y este es el mayor temor de los
mercados bursátiles ahora mismo están en
una delgada línea entre la inflación y
la recesión bueno hoy naciones unidas
presentó las cifras del hambre a nivel
global más de 800 millones de personas
sufrieron hambre en el mundo por la
pandemia esto dice el estudio de
naciones unidas y no solo la pandemia
también la crisis climática provocó esta
cifra según estimaciones de cinco
agencias de la onu que advirtieron de
que si la situación continúa no se
alcanzará el objetivo de eliminar el
hambre cero para 2030 el informe sobre
el estado de la seguridad alimentaria y
la nutrición en el mundo donde aún no se
ven reflejados los efectos de la guerra
en ucrania señala que la pandemia dejó
al descubierto la fragilidad de los
sistemas agroalimentarios y las
desigualdades también el hambre en el
mundo aumentó en 2021 con alrededor de
2300 millones de personas que tienen
dificultades moderadas o graves para
obtener lo suficiente para comer la
subnutrición sigue aumentando en 2021 y
el informe estima que entre 700 2 y 828
millones de personas pasaron hambre el
año pasado el informe señala que el
hambre siguió aumentando en áfrica asia
y américa latina en 2021 pero a un ritmo
un poco más lento que entre 2019 2020
bueno y el jury lanka continúan las
protestas antigubernamentales
los manifestantes culpan al presidente
de gotabaya rajapaksa de la crisis
económica las personas tienen semanas
sufriendo escasez de combustible
electricidad de alimentos y otros
artículos y los médicos afirman que
ahora podría colapsarse también el
sistema de salud las medidas adoptadas
por rajapaksa como pedir ayuda
financiera india y china- no han logrado
poner fin a la escasez y mucho menos a
las protestas callejeras en todo el país
en su contra ahora los ciudadanos
dejaron sus vehículos en casa optan por
bicicleta para desplazarse y hacer su
vida o intentar hacer su vida de forma
cotidiana otra de las medidas que toman
los ciudadanos también es con arco en
línea a falta de gas para cocinar la
mala económica y la pandemia del cómic
19 dejaron al país sin poder pagar las
importaciones esenciales de alimentos
fertilizantes medicinas y combustibles
debido a la grave escasez de dólares que
todavía enfrenta ese país panorama
bastante complejo jorge usted muchas
gracias por esta ampliación económica ya
continuamos aquí en directo en directo
américa con directo a